dawn is with us in Indianapolis hey dawn
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thank
you thank you thank you for taking my
call sure well well my husband and I
well that's August of last year I drank
the kool-aid we started your program and
we paid off around $55,000 and we've
come up with a situation that we can't
cash flow and I'd like to know how you
would handle my mom passed away earlier
in the year and there's a large asset
that we know it's workers but in order
to move forward to make it all come
together we need to hire an attorney
when element stop-stop there's a large
asset in her estate and what's the more
than it's an asset my mom and stepdad
purchased when they were together they
were married and because it's not in her
name my stepfather is now saying that
it's not hers and you know that it's
hers so in order to do that we've been
told we need to hire an attorney okay
what is the large asset they bought some
property on the outskirts of Dallas back
in the 90s for about one hundred and
seventy four thousand dollars and if now
we're 3.8 million dollars okay and how
many heirs are there to your mom's
estate there's three okay and what proof
do you have that your mother has
ownership in this even though she's not
on the deed the fact that they were
married I know they did business
together
divorce pardon me that did they buy this
after they divorced no they were married
they were together for 30 years and my
mom passed away earlier in the year also
they were still married when she passed
away yeah sorry I wasn't clear on that
okay it was there no will
well they had a trust that they started
last fall and they had everything placed
into the trust that this large piece of
property it was actually under contract
and it fell through the
last year so the first of this year they
relisted it and they actually had an
offer around the time that she passed
but the property's not in the trust it
was not in the trust does she have a
will she does have a will it was poor
over will we had it probated because I
thought if we had it probated it would
force misreport over into that
particular trust into that particular
trust ok then every asset of hers pours
over into that trust right it's over
well that's how that works there's no
question about this he doesn't know it's
not her one thing that's not her he's
saying it's not hers he's saying she
doesn't have half an Earthship did she
and they were married for 30 years
yes ok all right so basically he's just
trying to screw you kids yes and it only
came up when he had a 24 year old that
he's met now married - yeah how old is
this guy 77 Wow okay well that's weird
okay well I would think that if you have
a case and I don't know if you do or not
I'm not a lawyer it sounds like you at
least have something to argue about here
your share of this would in most states
I don't have no idea but in most states
the kids would get half that you divide
among the three of you so it's a million
and a half so your share on this a half
million dollars okay if you got a half
and the three kids got half and the half
is one and a half right he says three no
you said 3.8 so it's gonna be a little
more than that but you know bottom line
is your six seven hundred thousand bucks
is your part net if you won right right
so you ought to be able to get an
attorney to take that on contingency
meaning they get paid when they win how
do I find one of those attorneys you
find more they're gonna charge you a
percentage of what they win okay and
it's gonna be you know be healthy like a
third
quarter something like that but but I
want them doing that anyway and then I
want them to fight to win because if
they get zero if they lose so they're
not going to take the case if they don't
think they can win it then I got to take
the case and run you sixty eighty
thousand bucks and legal fees into the
hole on your stupid credit card knowing
that they can't win if they're going to
get oh if they get zero losing and they
get a nice chunk if they win they're
gonna take the case if they think they
can win so you know what I would do is
just contact some where did where was
she when she passed away Texas she's in
Texas
yes the same county that they have the
property yet yeah let's start calling
some estate attorneys in Texas tell them
what you're doing and try to find
somebody to take it on contingency it's
not that unusual really it's a fairly
standard practice where there is a major
lawsuit like this and you need to do it
pretty quickly you need to nail this guy
fast before he and the 24 year old end
up in Mexico somewhere okay okay thank
you that's great advice yeah and that
way you're not having because I'm afraid
I don't know if you got a case I mean
you're gonna have to have some real
proof you have to put some things
together but the fact that they were
married 30 years in in most states
that's going to give her some rights
whether her name is on the deed or not
and you probably could you know provide
some proof that her income her assets in
some way contributed to the original
purchase of this property but yeah
grandpa needs his brain straightened out
sounds like good gracious me yeah advice
from a 24 year old when you're 77 on
legal matters that'll get you in trouble
right there oh my goodness open phones a
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you just can't make this stuff up
by the way that's another case and I
have seen them for thirty years and
doing this that says not only do you
need a will but you need to read the
will
everyone involved and tell them what
your intent is and so if mom is ill as
an example if it's a predictable event
if it wasn't a car wreck or something
then she's got her will she sits down
with you know her husband and her kids
all together and in the presence of all
of them goes over what this means
and then you've got witnesses of what
her intent was and if you know if Papa
is gonna balk at that point
oh no then you can start making some
moves while she's alive
to fight through some of these things
always know your will always have a will
and always have everybody that's
involved in the will know what the will
says have a reading of the will while
you're alive if it doesn't to be a
formal thing but everybody needs to know
what's going on and this is what it says
and I don't you give them a copy of it
it doesn't to be a big secret this does
have to be like a bad movie script and
that's how a lot of this ends up this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]